[Music]
in america's election headquarters
tonight we told you a moment ago
early voting began here in florida today
it started saturday in nevada
a short time ago former president barack
obama held
a rally in las vegas to gin up
enthusiasm for democrats
running in close races for the senate
the house and the governor's
office there correspondent peter ducey
is in las vegas tonight
hello nevada barack obama won nevada
twice but senator dean heller trying to
win re-election against congresswoman
jackie rosen
thinks that's plenty the big difference
between her and i should take us back to
the obama era today
she did unlike some i actually try to
state facts i believe in facts the
former democratic president
is currently the party's top surrogate
and he rallied for rosen on the campus
of unlv
if republicans keep congress this fall
you better believe they are coming
after health care again
and millions of people across the
country who count on this are not going
to have it
even republicans they just don't know it
senator heller
thinks rosen's special guest will miss
the mark nevada was wiped out under the
obama administration we had 60 percent
of our homes
60 percent of the homes were underwater
here in the state two years into his
first
term with the 2010 elections approaching
president obama had a 45 percent
approval rating
and democrats lost the house two years
into president trump's first
term with the 2018 elections approaching
his approval rating is two points higher
47 percent and he's trying to use it to
help
heller i have to thank dean heller for
helping us
with justice gorsuch and justice
kavanaugh
rosen is trying to paint heller as too
tight with trump
he's rubber stamped every one of trump's
nomination
without even giving a second thought
nevada's want an independent voice
heller dismisses that charge as empty
rhetoric and believes the tax reform
bill is a bigger issue to voters here
than ties to trump in the first two days
of early voting democratic voters cast
45 percent of the ballots
republicans cast 36 percent but senator
heller likes his chances because
he thinks the kavanaugh confirmation
chaos kept the gop
excited just long enough let me tell you
what
my concern on all this was is that kevin
i have kavanagh happened to quit
i wanted that momentum to continue too
early voting to the first day of
early voting and it has occurred
president obama's pitch here on behalf
of democratic candidates was less about
their records and more about his
own especially when he was talking about
the economy but the crowd
ate it up roughly 2 000 people came
to hear him speak that is less than half
though
the size of the crowd that president
trump attracted on saturday up in elko
nevada
brett peter ducey live in las vegas
peter thank you